The following
content is provided
under a creative
commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: That's
the starting point,
but we're going to then move,
in the latter half of the class,
to what to make of it, what
happens if you find that it's
complete or incomplete,
how to think
about policy through
the lens of this model,
how to design insurance
instruments, what damage they
actually might do, what the
distribution of benefits
might be.
There is a recurring
theme today,
which wouldn't surprise
you, knowing me, which
is theory is guiding
the whole discussion,
rather than starting with
some randomized control trial
and targeting, but we
will get to those control
trials in the discussion.
OK.
So here's the outline.
We'll look at risk and
insurance and village
India, move to a
benchmark way of measuring
the effectiveness of
financial institutions
on the formal side.
We'll then couple that with
work on the informal side
and networks and so on.
We'll get to this--
can well-intended
interventions actually
result in well welfare losses?
And then issues of why insurance
take up in many circumstances
is actually quite low.
The idea here is that
people in village India,
and developing economies
more generally,
live in very high-risk
environments.
There are ways to
cope with this risk--
ex-ante and ex-post.
Ex-ante, you can diversify
your crops, fields, activities,
and occupations.
Ex-post, you can have financial
transactions, gifts, loans.
I actually mentioned
this the first lecture.
How well are households doing?
So the idea in this
paper is forget
enumerating all the mechanisms.
You're likely to miss one
anyway and the measurement
might be really bad.
Let's just look at the outcomes.
The null hypothesis-- If
risk sharing were perfect,
what would you expect to see
in consumption and income data?
I think this style of work,
although nowadays it's
not only accepted, it's highly
utilized all over the place,
but initially there was a
confusion that perfect means
complete as incomplete
markets, and somehow you're
saying you're going to have all
these Arrow-Debreu securities
being traded in a
village economy,
and no, that's not the idea.
Informal institutions can be
at work, as well as some spot
market exchanges.
You don't need to take
a stand on any of that
if you're just going to
look at the outcomes.
So the idea is
individual consumption
should actually not depend on
individual income, stunningly.
Once you control for
aggregate consumption,
it's as if all these households
lived in a big risk syndicate,
and they were just pooling
all their grain and so
on in one big pile, and
then depending on shares,
and some people are
more equal than others,
they get a fraction
of the grain.
A pile of the grain can go up
and down with village aggregate
shocks, but controlling
for those shocks,
your contribution has nothing
to do with what you take out.
So where to test?
We're going to do these
tests at the village
level in this starting point of
this lecture, but we'll move.
It could be kinship
networks within a village,
family related people.
It could be bigger than that.
It could be a
cross-village risk sharing.
It could be that being a member
of a financial institution,
for example, is allowing
you to be part of a larger
risk pooling population.
So it's a judgment call
about where to apply it.
Fortunately in the work
today, I can show you it
being applied at various
distinct levels, which
is a theme we'll come back
to next Thursday as well.
Why did I choose villages?
I had some idea that
everybody knows each other,
and the environment
is relatively simple,
and it just seemed like
the idealized setting.
Of course, in practice not
all villages are alike,
and they're pretty
complicated, and you've
got people interacting
with one another,
and they don't all
love each other.
But that was the
motivation to begin with.
By the way, if there's
no idiosyncratic risk
there's nothing to test,
because the benchmark
says controlling
for the aggregate is
the idiosyncratic influencing
consumption or not.
And if there's no idiosyncratic,
it's all aggregate,
you can't do that test.
This extends, of course,
beyond households
within a village to tests
across villages and so on.
Now, many people have the
idea that villages which
they may never go
into are all alike,
and it's all a function
of the rainfall,
and it's all aggregate, and
that's just not true at all.
And I'll show you the front end
of this paper, some statistics.
Although it is true there
may be a lot of diversity
in a village, if they all
completely diversified
and did not specialize and they
all held a common portfolio,
then, again, there
would be nothing
to test as if they're doing it
all ex-ante and not ex-post,
because the starting point would
be the income coming from all
these diversified activities.
But again, they don't do that.
So let's take a look, these
so-called ICRISAT villages--
Institute for Crops Research
in the Semi-Arid Tropic--
at one point that was the source
of virtually the only panel
data on developing
countries in the world.
And it was gathered monthly,
and essentially for 10 years.
They've started it up
again, interestingly.
And there are other data
sets like that, where
there are gaps of decades.
So it's not true that
ICRISAT was the only source
of panel variation.
In Aurepalle, they're
growing castor and sorghum.
Each crop is quite risky if
you look at the coefficient
of variation.
Those numbers are
comparable to something
I did in medieval England,
where roughly every 12,
13 years, they would
experience a famine.
So these are high-risk
environments.
Of course you could
diversify across these crops.
That helps.
Depending on the pair
of crops that you pick,
the cross-crop correlations
could be as low as 0.09
or something much higher.
A low number is a good
thing, because you
can spread your risk.
Soil isn't uniform either.
You can look, for a
given crop, at how
the coefficient of variation
varies from one type of soil
to another.
And again, the cross-soil
correlation for a given crop
is 0.37, and relatively low.
Nevertheless, as I
said, it's not true
that all households hold
a diversified basket
of all these things.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Are there any
crops that are negatively
correlated with each other?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Not
in these numbers,
although I certainly
wouldn't rule it out.
Well, and some of those
numbers are point estimates,
relatively low.
And you put the standard
error bands, and yeah.
OK.
This is by cruder categories,
like labor income, income
from trade and handicrafts,
animal husbandry.
And it's stratified, as ICRISAT
did, by the amount of land
that they hold--
none, small, medium,
and large landholders.
And these are sort of
basically fractions of income
that they get from such things.
Large landholders have the bulk
of their income from crops,
and a substantial amount
from animal husbandry.
People without land virtually
have no crop income.
And the dominant
source is from labor.
And there's everything
else in between,
as you might anticipate.
There were three
villages involved.
That pattern is pretty common.
And here, again, by
those income sources--
(EXCITEDLY) hey, a
negative number--
again, in the lower bound of
the stair of the confidence
interval.
Well, actually this is--
even the point
estimates went negative.
Sorry, no no.
Yes, yes.
This is hard to read because
these items should also
be listed on the rows.
So if you're going
down the diagonal,
you're reading the
coefficient of variation,
and then above and
below the diagonal,
you're reading the
correlation of, say,
in this case, livestock
income with profit income.
It just throws you off, because
it should be written down here.
And then to avoid
double counting,
you don't fill in the
bottom of the matrix.
So I've shown you
this picture before,
the Rocky Mountain picture,
arguably the most famous graph
I've ever produced.
This is 10 years of data.
And then the households
are lined up--
which is why I keep showing it--
the households are
lined up roughly
by the size of landholdings.
And you can see the levels
kind of going up as they
have more and more land.
And there's a 0 here.
And so everything
on this diagram
is deviation from the village
average at a point in time.
Some people are below and
some people are above.
You're seeing that
in the cross section,
and you're seeing
that over time.
The point of the diagram,
I've said before,
is that some of the valleys
lie behind the peaks.
And that means not everyone
is experiencing good years
and bad years at the same time.
It's not like undulating
waves of grain, as in Kansas.
This is the consumption
picture that
is on the same scale
as the income picture.
If I wanted to get
bigger differences,
I could rescale this graph.
You know, it's all just
suppressed down there.
But the statistical
work is really
testing to see if there
are common fixed effects,
and also whether this diagram
somehow, through the lens
of the model, is related to
the income diagram previously.
AUDIENCE: Have you
observed this in terms
of like greater
weights on people?
Because it looks like there's
not only risk-sharing,
but also the rich guys are--
if it's the same [INAUDIBLE].
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah, exactly.
AUDIENCE: They're not
just getting the average.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: That's right.
So risk-sharing is
sometimes misinterpreted
to mean complete pooling, and
everyone has an equal share.
And that's not necessary.
And when we look at the
benchmark regression,
essentially it
has fixed effects.
And those fixed effects
are almost exactly
the Pareto weights.
And then we can
test and see what
those weights are related to.
So here's the
optimization problem.
You just basically-- there
is a one-to-one relationship
between all the Pareto-optimal
allocations in this economy
and solutions to this
programming problem.
And that's asking about
the Pareto weights.
Here they are-- lambda
sub-k, different
for different households, k.
The household is the
basic unit, although we
will control for
the demographics
within the household.
So just to read
across this, it's
a weighted average, lambda,
Pareto-weighted average
of the discounted
expected utility of, say,
in this case, household k.
OK, so it's over time, which
could be finite or infinite.
It's discounted
at a common rate.
I'll come back to that.
It's presumed everyone
has equal probability
over these states of the world.
And these states of
the world are not just
the contemporaneous
realization of all the shocks.
It's the entire history, from
the initial date out to that,
like the branches of a tree.
And then utility
contemporaneously
depends on consumption and
these gender/age weights.
So and you just want to--
whatever sums of consumption
is, it's this average
and the aggregate.
And then the idea is how to
distribute that aggregate
to maximize this
subjective function.
You can put labor in here.
We'll have a whole
lecture on that.
So what is the solution?
Let's just pick consumption
of household k at date t
is entering in here,
and it's entering
in this resource constraint.
This supplies, you know, for
the whole history of states
up to date, t,
for every date, t.
So we're going to
get derivative here,
and a Lagrange multiplier here.
This is common
resource constraints.
So you pick up a common
Lagrange multiplier.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Does the [? ht ?]
include the use of [INAUDIBLE]
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yes.
Yep.
A complete enumeration of
everything, and not just crops,
but babies, and deaths, and the
whole demographic structure.
So again, taking
that derivative,
putting this thing
over here, you'd
get a beta-discounted
probability, lambda k weighted
marginal utility.
And everyone's margin
utility is being
equated to this common
Lagrange multiplier.
You know, so if you assumed a
particular exponential utility
function, for example,
then you can actually
get sort of closed-form
analytic solutions
for these first-order
conditions.
So this just says, in
levels, that the consumption
of household k depends
on the Pareto--
the log Pareto weight
of household k.
It has something to do with
the demographics and something
to do with this common
shadow price of consumption,
if I dare call it that.
So here are the levels that
we were just talking about.
This is too small to
read, but basically--
another nice thing about
that exponential utility,
if you're willing to
make strong assumptions
about the composition
of the household,
is it basically would
dictate how to weight people.
And little babies don't eat
as much as 18-year-old males.
And in turn, consumption is
dropping for the elderly.
So we actually had
a dietary survey.
And we assumed that
strong functional form,
and we made all
those corrections.
So you don't actually
see people eating.
So you don't see their
individual consumptions.
You see the consumption
for the whole household, k,
but you put it in per
capita terms by dividing
by the age/gender-weighted
number of people.
Likewise, this
thing over here is
the sum in the whole population
of per-capita consumption.
And sort of reading
out loud, this term
is actually the risk tolerance,
the inverse risk aversion,
of household k.
It's actually a j here.
Sorry.
Household j relative
to the sum of the risk
tolerances of all
the other households.
And I'll come back
to this often.
If you assumed homogeneous risk
aversion, which is standard,
then this ought to have
a coefficient of 1.
So everybody's consumption
is co-moving, one to one,
with the per capita average.
If you have different
risk aversions,
there is a very nice
interpretation here, which
is this is aggregate risk.
This is what's left over
after all the other smoothing
that they're doing
intertemporally, blah, blah,
blah, than what
they actually eat.
So this is like the macro risk.
And then the higher this
risk tolerance, the more they
should be willing to bear
that, quote, "helping"
out their village neighbors
who might be quite risk-averse.
And we'll come back
to that in terms
of measuring risk aversion.
OK, so here's the standard
regression equation.
If the level of consumption
depends on basically
what is now a constant
household-specific term, which
are those Pareto weights,
sum-- coefficients, time,
village average
consumption-- at date t,
adjustment for demographics,
and something else that
ought to be zero, like income.
You're going to have a devil
of a time running this.
Even when you run one
household at a time ignoring
all the others, even when
you use the leave out mean--
so the household
is not included--
it will turn out,
amazingly enough,
that these coefficients,
one for each household, when
you average them up, have
to take on the value of 1.
So there are sort of
econometric issues
here that you could
mistakenly think
that you've got a
lot of co-movement,
and it's just going to
happen-- you know, why is this
happening, essentially?
Well, it's more obvious if you
had the panel in front of us
rather than one
household at a time.
You're looking at household
consumption on the left,
and the average of household
consumption on the right.
Now take the average
of the whole thing,
and the averages appearing
on the left and the right,
and it ought to take
on a value of 1.
So the average tendency
of the dependent variable
is kind of like an intercept.
So that's kind of the intuition.
This also comes up in
many situations where you
have this confounding problem.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] talked
about [? instead of their ?]
[? compatibility? ?]
ROBERT TOWNSEND: No,
because we're going
to assume full commitment--
instead of compatibility?
Did I hear you correctly?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
We can put in
incentive constraints.
And we will later.
So we're going to build
on this basic framework,
and get to all the
obstacles to trade,
and how to estimate them.
But you may think this thing
would be rejected out of hand.
And it is statistically
rejected most of the time.
But it turns out to be a
very, very useful benchmark.
So this is the time series,
one household at a time.
I won't say much
about this other
than, does the data
have any power.
The problem is, you test one
null, like full risk-sharing.
And you can't reject it because
the confidence intervals
are so large.
So you want to test other
things like its autarky.
And the weight of the
evidence is it's not autarky.
We can pretty much
soundly reject--
And risk-sharing is
doing quite well.
And this is with a panel.
And again, I'm going to
spare you all the details.
But we did it three
different ways--
standard, first
difference, Jerry Hausman--
and estimated.
Now, here we're
picking up coefficients
on various sources of
income, none of which
should be positive
and significant.
But some of them kind of are.
For example, the
highest number here
is profits from trade and
handicrafts in Aurepalle.
They're climbing palm
trees and tapping--
and then making liquor, toddy.
And it's not insured, evidently.
Labor in general has a
high number pretty much
in all the villages.
So now we're kind of easing
into the policy thing, which
is, if you wanted a
target, wouldn't you
want to run this thing
first and see who's
the most vulnerable,
and then sort of guide
your interventions.
Based on that, I wasn't
thinking along that line,
I was just being
honest about where
we're rejecting and so on.
And here, finally, Matt, is
where we took this coefficient
and regressed it
against other things
like the area operated by
the household, the value
of their plow animals,
their inheritance,
and so on and so forth.
And I'm not sure what
you would expect.
It looks good at first
blush, in the sense
that the amount of land and
the value of the animals
is correlated with
those intercepts.
The problem is things are
more turbulent than that
at the village level.
And people do sell, or
buy, or acquire land.
And certainly those
plow animals aren't just
locked in place year
after year after year.
So that's kind of some
evidence of some kind
of long-term impact that shows
up in terms of the assets
they end up holding.
And that's very much
along the lines of,
is there a moral hazard
problem or some kind
of incentive constraint?
And how should wealth levels
behave if that were the case?
The biggest puzzle in
these data, in some sense,
is almost the opposite,
which is although we see them
over 10 years, we see the
upper-caste, white-robed
brahman-type guys in the
village just consistently eating
far less than their
income, constantly.
And so is this just a
social transfer mechanism,
or are they actually
insuring themselves
against future relabeling of--
castes, by the way
do get relabeled,
and histories get recreated.
It it's a much more complicated
history than you might--
at least that's what the
anthropologists tell me.
OK, so that's risk and
insurance in village India.
So let's take that framework
and start knocking off
some policy questions.
So first is about
the effectiveness
of financial institutions.
Now, let me just say, the
immediate policy implication
coming out of village
India was basically,
miraculously, somehow,
they're pooling all that risk.
It's not a bunch of fragmented
households on their own,
in autarky.
It seems to be
more the opposite.
So there was a huge
firestorm people
had a hard time accepting
that something like that
could happen.
But villages, even if they
were amazingly good not,
are not necessarily
interacting with each other.
I'll come back to that.
And there may be, as there
is in Thailand, transactions
with outside financial
institutions.
So the question is, do outside
formal financial institutions
help, if not within the
village, then across village,
in the mitigation of risk?
So roughly speaking,
the treatment group
is a set of households
who are customers
of financial institutions.
A little typo there.
And that's measured-- their
use of the institution
is actually measured in the
data, which is reassuring.
And I'll tell you about the
instruments we use momentarily.
So we're going to go back to
that consumption equation,
and also derive a corresponding
investment equation,
and then see whether being
a customer or a member
lowers the vulnerability
in the sense
of that coefficient
on idiosyncratic risk.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So when we say
those with financial access
are compared to those
without, so does
that really mean
those with access
to the formal financial
sector are compared without--
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
That's what it means.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, because
there's money-lending sectors
et cetera.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: So yeah,
that's like one topic away.
I'll come right back to that.
But to answer your
question, it's
going to turn out that
directly connected,
at least in consumption,
is helpful, but indirectly
connected, through
gifts and loans
to someone in the village,
even though you're not,
is as effective in
consumption-smoothing.
So that's then consistent
with the previous paper,
although it's not quite
so clean with investment.
So what are these institutions?
Well, by now you probably
know the names of them.
They've been coming up
in previous lectures.
We find that this
bank for agriculture
and agricultural cooperatives
is helpful in smoothing
consumption and investment.
It looks, from the
transactions data,
is if that has to do with
its credit operation.
They're basically embedding
credit and insurance
in their loan contracts.
It's not, "you pay back
the loan or default."
There's a whole
schedule for repayment.
And it's adjusted by aggregate
local/regional shocks,
and so on.
It's quite sophisticated.
In the financial
crisis, the World Bank
went in there determined to
see this stereotype everywhere,
since remember, finance
companies and commercial bank
failures triggered the
Asia financial crisis.
So they looked at the BAAC
history of over arrears,
and concluded that it
was another disaster.
But actually they were running
an insurance operation.
And that's what shows up
in the consumption data.
Commercial banks are
helping to smooth somewhat.
It's largely, though, through
formal savings accounts.
Loans are pretty
thin in the data.
So what are we going to do?
You've seen this model before.
This is Greenwood and Javanovic.
By the way, we're sort of in the
data micro part of the class.
Don't forget about
all that macro.
So the Greenwood-Jovanovic
model assumes
that the benefit of being
in a financial institution
is better information
and risk-sharing.
So here we are
looking at the data
to see if that's a
good assumption or not,
actually institution
by institution.
So there is a direct,
immediate link
of this micro work with
those macro models.
Or even if we reject,
then it should
inform what we assume
within those macro models.
So remember, in
Greenwood and Javanovic,
there was a cost to joining
the financial system.
We're going to let this be
a household-specific cost.
And basically we're
going to want something
like instruments, like
distance from the branch, which
varies across households.
Just a little bit on
the underlying model,
just to remind you, because
you've actually seen it before.
You've got output, which is a
function of the current capital
stock, and then the sum of an
aggregate idiosyncratic shock,
aggregate at the whatever
level, regional/national level,
idiosyncratic at the
level of the households.
As I said, we're going to
embed investment in this,
adding that to the risk and
insurance in village India.
So there's going to be some
adjustment costs to adjusting
your capital stock.
This is also buffeted
around by IID shocks.
This is new.
This is a preference shock.
We're going to put something
in the utility function which
is autocorrelated.
I'm actually bending
over backwards
to create a bias here.
What we're going to want to
be able to do an instrument is
to say that the
instrument has to do with,
does influence the
selection of being
a member of a
financial institution,
and conditioned on that, does
not influence the outcome,
in the future, at least.
But you can imagine, with
autocorrelated preference
shocks, that part
of the decision
to join the financial
institution today
has to do with that
urgency or patience.
And if that carries
on into the future,
it will also affect the
endogenous variables.
So we want to make
it hard, and then we
want to get rid of
the problem, to show
that we have the ability
to get rid of the problem.
You may remember how
this works, though.
You create a value function
for being a participant
in the financial system.
If you join, you subtract
off that fixed cost.
And this is just the array
of the other variables.
You're joining after the
realization of the adjustment
cost shock, the idiosyncratic
and aggregate shock,
and the preference shock.
You could choose not to join.
You'd have another
value function.
I think we even used V and
W in the earlier lecture.
So but you don't
subtract off the cost
from the capital stock.
If you saw the autarky problem,
then you've kind of already
seen the solution to
the consumption part
of the intermediated problem.
You can just sort of list
the equations for p equal 1,
participant.
They've got the
V value function.
You've got consumption as a
function of your preference
shock, and aggregate
consumption, and your Pareto
weight.
By the way, you haven't
seen this today,
but investment is also a
function of the adjustment
cost, the capital stock, and
the same aggregate consumption.
Because it's the same
resource constraint.
So the price of consumption
today, actually,
versus tomorrow, is
not only influencing
consumption, it's influencing
investment intertemporally.
And we'll come back
to that and repeat it
in the lecture on Thursday.
And this is just the
autarky equation.
You don't see aggregate
consumption anywhere.
People are on their
own, and so on.
There's no way you
could see and totally
understand all the individual
variables at this level.
I'm going too fast for that.
But I just want you to think
about what you see in the data.
You're going to see kind
of a weighted average
of these things, weighted
by participation.
So actually you're
either in this branch
or you're in this one.
And being an instrument
for these Ps.
But anyway, it's convenient
to write it down this way,
and derive the sort of
econometric equations
you're going to
take to the data.
I actually take
first differences,
but the same principle applies.
These instruments are the
history of the person's
institutional use.
Like predetermined
variables is an indicator
for their current participation
at the village level,
actually, not at
the household level.
The time to the district
center is the most compelling.
That's like how long does
it take to get to the bank.
And then we have some
GIS measure of access
in the local area, which is
supposed to pick up, like,
their active credit
officers in one spot
and some not-so-active credit
officers in other areas.
And then the data you know,
this was from May of 1997,
in this case, when we wrote
this paper, through 2001.
And I already gave you
the conclusions basically.
And in fact you're going
to see the equations again
when we get to this
informal, because it's
very similar-looking
no point in repeating.
So this is what I've been doing
with Cynthia and [? Whit. ?]
So we have the measured chains
of financial transactions,
gifts and loans, from
one family to another.
So we've already
talked about the fact
that people with
indirect connections who
are not directly
customers but are
connected through
other households
are going to do quite well.
There's a flip side
to that, is we've been
measuring the control group.
The control group was
an average of people
who were indirect previously,
indirectly connected or not
connected at all.
And when we separate
that out, we
have the "not connected
at all" people.
And it turns out they're
actually the most vulnerable.
So their vulnerability
was being concealed.
And there's some work in Mexico
that is very, very similar
in spirit.
The data is a bit
different, so the details
are a bit different, Andgelucci,
and Rangel, Rasul, and so on.
Investment's going to be a
bit of a different story.
Kin are going to
matter, but it's almost
like an
out-of-equilibrium story.
Let me come back to that.
I won't dwell on this slide.
It's just showing you that
there is a lot of borrowing,
and lending, and gift-giving.
And when it happens,
it happens typically,
you know, depending
on which line
you're looking at, three to
five times during a sample.
And the amounts are large.
The borrowing transaction is
like 60% your monthly income.
So you know, take your
student stipend and--
it's a big number.
No, I'm not saying your stipend.
It's a big percent.
AUDIENCE: [CHUCKLES]
We would never
make that misunderstanding
[INAUDIBLE]..
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
[CHUCKLES] So this
is the equation I was alluding
to that I didn't show you
on the previous paper with Alem.
But basically,
first-differenced, we
have the change in
household consumption
in village v at date t.
This is the change in
the income of household
i in village v at date t.
This is the
vulnerability coefficient
that we're interested in
seeing how big or small it is.
And then we start interacting
that change in income with
basically a direct member or
"indirectly-connected," quote,
member of a financial
institution.
And one hopes that this
might be not trivial,
but this would be
negative and subtract off
for those who are members,
and customers, and so on.
K is kinship.
That's also entering--
we're trying
to distinguish sort
of having family
in the village as opposed to
having measured transactions.
It's a bit heroic.
We don't have instruments
for whether you're
in a network or not.
It's a problem for us and
for a lot of this literature.
And then this is
controlling for net worth.
I mean, as you've seen from the
previous slides, the relatively
poor people, at least in
India, were more vulnerable.
So knowing that
a priori, we want
to take that effect out and
control for it, at least
in this additive way.
This is the investment equation.
It's basically very similar.
I is just investment.
It's actually normalized
by the capital stock.
So it's investment
per unit capital.
And again, it allows
for the direct effect
of the income per
unit of capital,
as well as the direct
and indirect connections.
I should have highlighted that,
in both of these equations,
you've got these time-varying
calm and fixed effects.
This is what the theory
is telling us to do.
It's not as though consumption
doesn't move with income.
Consumption can move
with this fixed effect.
I should have also
said, previously,
with my mention of the
econometric problems
of measuring average
consumption and putting it
on the right-hand
side, that you can just
replace that with an
unobserved fixed effect.
And the theory gives you the
interpretation of what it is.
Or you could subtract it all
off from the left-hand side.
And when the
coefficient is 1, that's
also a reasonable thing to do.
Here we're just putting in these
time-varying fixed effects.
So this is the coefficient
for those people
without any access,
direct or indirect.
This is how much you'd subtract
if you look at direct bank--
yes, these are very
similar numbers.
I always get accused
of biasing this stuff.
Anyway, so the sum
of these things
is significantly
different from zero.
And the point is you've
achieved the benchmark standard.
But equally interesting
is, when you
have the indirect connections,
you're subtracting off
virtually the same number.
Kin didn't help in this case.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, is
there a way to augment--
because we have
direct connection
and indirect connection.
Would it help me
more to have both?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: That's
what indirect means.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
All right.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah, yeah.
It's mislabeled.
It means both.
AUDIENCE: Oh, all right.
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
Yeah, good point.
And then this is
with investment.
Now, what are the differences?
Well, two, basically.
First of all, whatever
we're subtracting off,
it doesn't lower
the total to zero.
And if you tested, there's
still residual vulnerability.
So with investment, smoothing
investment against cash flow,
you are left with some
idiosyncratic risk.
Although kin are quite
helpful, but measured
transactions are not.
It's a little too early
to get into this story.
Cynthia and I are
still working on it.
But the idea is
something like, just
to anticipate when we get
to obstacles to trade,
you can't force someone to
be in a risk-sharing group,
but they kind of
like being there
because they can smooth
their future income.
So you can't force them,
but they voluntarily
choose to stay even
though, in any period,
they have the option to leave.
It's, like, self-sustaining.
With investment-- and this
is above median investment
relative to the capital stock--
investment is big.
The typical number is like
20% of your physical capital
when it happens.
So it's not little,
incremental, teeny-weeny stuff.
OK, now imagine, say,
someone comes to me
and asks me for a loan--
I'm the community head, in
case you didn't notice--
and you're going to
put it in your project,
and it's quite a good project.
And then, next period,
you got a lot more income
than you used to, now it's
much more tempting to renege.
Because you're much better
off in autarky than you
would have been if you hadn't
gotten the investment done.
And so the theory is, A, that
either doesn't happen, or B,
all your relatives come
and do their thing.
And that's consistent
with these patterns
when we're working on
numerical estimates.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I'm not sure if you
can see this from this data,
but if I'm talking indirectly,
accessing the financial system,
is that link between us,
does that person typically
have assets on stock,
perhaps, because they
know people will borrow from
them, and they want to do it?
Or are they actually just
turning around and then
borrowing the
pharmacist, and then
being more like an
intermediary for a loan.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: I'm not sure
exactly what you're asking.
[? Whit ?] and I have this--
somebody will take a
formal-sector loan.
Then it's due.
And they're not doing
too well in that year.
So they will turn around and
get an informal short-term loan
from a friend, or
relative, or money lender,
pay off the long-term
loan, and then
with the proceeds of
the long-term loan, they
pay off the short-term loan.
AUDIENCE: And that friend
or relative, should I--
maybe the answer is it's both--
should I think of that person
as having money lying
around to be ready to lend
to their friend who needs
it, or did they intend to--
AUDIENCE: They
can also take it--
there could be a lot of shame.
And they could also get it
from the financial institution
themself if they're
a normal guy.
But there is some people who
are acting as money lender,
and they have money
ready [INAUDIBLE]..
So it depends on the person.
If it's a relative, mostly
they're not that rich.
So they'd probably borrow.
AUDIENCE: I guess
I'm just speaking
of one of the things the
portfolios and the [INAUDIBLE]
book, is that people will
simultaneously borrow and save
at the same time.
And maybe this fits in,
if part of the reason
I have that savings is because
I might need to lend it out
at short notice to somebody.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
So there are all kinds
of financial strategies.
You know, savings and borrowing
gets pretty complicated.
Because even if you get
a loan, then the way
you get the loan
proceeds is someone
opens up a savings account.
You don't necessarily
withdraw it right away.
So that's one mechanical
reason to get that.
But loans can be long term.
And then you have a
liquidity problem.
And you don't call in the loan.
So you might want to keep
savings to balance that risk.
I mean, this is like
the bread and butter
of a lot of things
people do in macro
when they're looking
at investment
and trying to sort all that out.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: Why [INAUDIBLE]
smallest investment?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: They want
to undertake the investment
when they have an opportunity.
And they may not
be able to do it,
or they may have
to wait to do it
until they have the liquidity.
And that's costly.
AUDIENCE: But [INAUDIBLE]
differentiate [INAUDIBLE]
tp avoid two cases.
The first one is that there
is insufficient insurance,
so I cannot borrow
money from the bank.
The second one is that I
[? just ?] [? want ?] to invest
because productivity
[INAUDIBLE]..
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah, so we'll
get to this structural model
of village funds, which takes
a stand on the process that
generate shocks.
And then we have to
take the data, and kind
of estimate that process.
And then that model allows the--
and then you get these
investment opportunities
which are like random variables,
large, chunky opportunities.
AUDIENCE: Here we assume that
we don't have to differentiate
[INAUDIBLE]
ROBERT TOWNSEND: This
is reduced form--
I mean, here, I was talking
about a model just then.
But we're not quite ready in
the class, because we haven't
really explicitly written
down these obstacles,
neither the moral hazard
or the limited commitment.
So I was talking you
through it like what next.
But actually this is
just reduced-form stuff.
It doesn't really tell you.
But we're telling a story which
I think is reasonably accurate.
But Cynthia and I are
writing down a model,
and trying to
numerically compute
it to see if it's
a reasonable story.
This is what I said in words.
And then this is
the Mexican paper.
So it has to do with Progresa.
And they have
treatment and control.
And the details are
a bit different.
But I think you
have these slides.
And there's only like
four or five of them.
But I will just say, then,
it's not just about Thailand,
and we're not the
only one doing this.
Networks is a really hot topic.
Everybody wants to play
around with networks.
Esther and [? Arun ?] have
pretty good network data
in parts of India.
So one example
probably is enough.
Now, I said something about
well-intended interventions
causing losses.
This is some joint
work We first of all do
estimate heterogeneity
and risk preferences.
And then the idea, splicing
together these papers,
it's like village India.
So there's aggregate
village level risk that's
not necessarily shared very--
which you have to control for,
and it's not "shared," quote,
unquote--
let me say it again.
You've got all the
idiosyncratic stuff
going on within the village.
So it's as if almost
complete markets there.
Then you village-level risk,
which is aggregate risk.
And then someone comes
in ostensibly trying
to insure that aggregate risk.
So you would think, oh great,
they're already covered
on the idiosyncratic side.
Now someone else can
come in and cover them
on the aggregate side.
Must be a good thing.
And the answer is, well,
no, not necessarily.
I've already basically
given this away.
Because you have
risk-tolerant people
in the village who were
willing to underwrite
that aggregate risk.
And it shows up in higher
levels of consumption for them,
on average.
It's not as though
people wrote a check,
and you got the premium.
But it's showing up,
in whatever mechanism
it is, in the give-and-take
with informal transactions
and so on.
So to see how
we're estimating it
and get some intuition for how
we estimate the risk aversion,
if two households had more
or less the same coefficient
of risk tolerance,
then their consumption
should more or
less move together.
But the opposite, if one were
very almost risk-neutral,
and the other very risk-averse,
then, practically, consumption
is almost smooth
for the risk-averse
guy by virtue of
the risk-neutral guy
underwriting that risk.
So you can imagine-- and
people have done this--
looking at households
pairwise, and just
trying to see how many
consumption reversals there
are, and things.
We don't quite do that.
We don't have enough data.
And I'm not sure it's very
effective econometrically.
We do take a household, j, take
their measure of co-movement,
essentially, compared to
the co-movements of all
the other households.
So it's always j,
less time, compared
with all the other ones.
Well, it's probably easier
to do it with the notation.
So here is that basic
first-order condition.
With constant relative
risk-aversion, by the way,
it's in logs, not levels.
But it's the same idea.
You've got the Pareto weight.
We're actually going to allow
differences in discount rates
across households.
And so that sends
sets up a trend,
where some people are going up
and some people are going down
long term.
We allow preference shocks--
actually monthly shocks, because
there are holidays and things.
So the idea is to put as many
controls in, in some sense,
that the theory would allow.
And then we have this sort
of common fixed effect.
And note in particular
that actually everything,
but in particular this
thing, is normalized
by basically the risk aversion.
If risk aversion is really high,
this coefficient is really low,
and so that household's
not moving around
with the aggregate.
So basically-- sorry--
almost what we're doing
is taking consumption,
regressing it
against trends, and
monthly effects,
and household fixed effects,
and getting a residual.
The residual is
capturing all of this--
call it v or eta, and
then just sort of see.
What the correlation
is between a household
i's residual, which is a
stand-in for that aggregate
that's moving consumption, and
any other household's i-prime.
So this is like a
moment, basically.
And we can use
method of moments,
in principle, for all
the households, pairwise.
But we didn't have
enough data for that,
even though we have a lot of
households and a lot of months.
So we just summed that we have
household i's risk tolerance--
essentially what this
thing turns out to be
is household i's risk
tolerance times the sum
of the risk toleri of the other
households in the village.
But hopefully you're
getting some intuition
for where we're getting
the risk aversion measures.
This, I think, you
can ignore today.
It has to do with whether or
not the conventional regressions
that ignored heterogeneity
are biased in some way.
And early work--
actually Sam's work--
suggested that it's even harder
to reject full risk-sharing
if you allow for
the heterogeneity.
Or it could seem that you're
rejecting full risk-sharing
when you assume homogeneity,
because you haven't allowed
this asymmetric
adjustment that's
possible on the
part of households,
depending on their
risk tolerance.
And that's all I want to say,
probably even false intuition.
Because it may not
be true in general.
But then you kind of want
to measure welfare gains.
OK, so how much
would a household
be willing to pay living
in a risky situation
to remove that risk.
In other words, what fraction
of average consumption would
they be willing to take a
hit on and live in a world
without the risk, as
opposed to the world
that they're currently in.
Or how much would they be
willing to pay for someone
to come in as an outsider
targeting insurance
against, say, rainfall?
Lucas did this with
business cycles.
So this number, k, which
is the fraction you're
willing to give up, if
positive means that you
gain from eliminating
aggregate risk, but k
can actually turn
out to be negative.
Here is an expression for it.
Suffice it to say that it has
to do with the risk tolerance.
And although this slide is a bit
tiny, village by village, this
is 0.
So basically we're
lining up the households
by their degree of tolerance,
from very risk-averse to not
very.
And these are
downward-sloping lines.
So basically the higher this
risk tolerance, the more likely
it is that this k or this
welfare gain is negative.
So it's not trivial.
And by the way, it's not
correlated with characteristics
either.
You say, oh, it's
the rich people.
No, that's wrong.
Risk aversion is not
correlated with wealth.
It's as if complete
markets, remember?
AUDIENCE: Could it be due to
[INAUDIBLE] within the village
[INAUDIBLE] institutions.
So two equally risk-averse
people, but one [INAUDIBLE]
so they [INAUDIBLE].
ROBERT TOWNSEND: We actually
initially did this just
on the network
households, because I
was worried about having
the non-network households
in there.
Although when we actually
run the full test now,
for risk-sharing, taking into
account the heterogeneity,
we don't reject either.
I don't totally believe it.
I still think there are
relatively poor people who tend
to be a little more vulnerable.
But somehow, with all
this heterogeneity,
it's not showing up the
way I would have thought.
It's not soundly
rejecting full insurance.
AUDIENCE: From the
data, can you see, then,
if the risk tolerance
is greater amongst--
is there a distinction between
risk tolerance and [INAUDIBLE]
network [INAUDIBLE]?
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
Oh, I'm not sure we
have enough non-network
households to do it.
But the counter to that
is that we certainly
had enough in network with
Cynthia to find something.
So it's probably worth trying.
I haven't done it yet.
Yeah, the worry here is that
we've left something out.
The model is just making a
lot of strong assumptions
that there's no alternatives.
To try to say it
in words, we're not
looking at some indirect
utility function.
We're looking at the
direct utility function.
And indirect might be there if
they have other ways of coping.
When we get to labor
supply, we will
be quite explicit
about supplying labor
as a way to cope with risk, and
then revisit these equations.
So people have--
I have, too-- offered insurance
products like rainfall
insurance in India.
We haven't quite done
it yet in Thailand.
And I'll tell you why we
have misgivings about it,
and some of the puzzles.
But basically with less of an
exception in Ghana and Chris
Udry, with Dean,
most experiments
in the world, the take-up
of these insurance products
is pretty low.
Or in our case, in India,
people will insure one plot,
and not insure the other
plots that they own.
So you know, it's
not totally terrible.
There is some price elasticity.
But there are puzzles.
I mean, if people are so
poor and so vulnerable,
then why aren't
taking it up more?
Now, one answer you
may have already seen.
They don't really need it.
Because even if they're
somewhat vulnerable,
there are people in the
village willing to assume
some of that risk.
And even if it isn't perfect,
at the end of the day, given
the way the policies
are priced, maybe you're
just not going to
see that take-up.
Unfortunately-- and people
aren't either taking
the time to get baseline data
or don't bother with it at all.
They just go in
there with an RCT.
Well, we did.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So is that
just rainfall insurance?
Or any kinds of insurance?
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
Could be anything.
I'm going to focus on
rainfall as just a way
to give it a label.
Could be any kind
of weather risk.
It could actually be price risk.
Case-Shiller index in the
US is about price risk.
It wasn't just to
measure housing prices
to get his name in The Wall
Street Journal every month.
It was originally designed
because Bob Shiller had spent
years creating a risk
instrument which he was trying
to promote on Wall Street.
So yeah, so it could be--
and in urban areas,
maybe it is more
likely to be vulnerability to
price rather than rainfall.
So rainfall here is kind
of like, partly, a metaphor
for the problem in general.
But I'll come back
with a vengeance
to look at rainfall in
these Thai villages.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
even summer and winter,
they say that rain
affects [INAUDIBLE]..
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
People don't come and buy
when it's raining, and so on.
But you came up with a situation
where it was actually good.
Just trying to
remember what it was.
AUDIENCE: I think
we said, umbrellas.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah,
something like that.
OK, so here's the vengeance
paper with Kamilya.
So this is all about rain.
So we want to see the effect
of rain on rice production.
Now again, the typical
thing that you'll
see in the
development literature
is rainfall is the risk.
Let's just sort of instrument
the relevant variable
by rainfall, and then
start looking at migration
and all kinds of stuff.
So here, the idea
is, let's just look
at rainfall in the village,
start instrumenting income
or rice production by
rainfall, and then look
at the vulnerability
of consumption
to instrumented income,
which people do, a lot.
Now, it's going to
turn out that things
are more complicated than
that within the village.
The soil is different.
The hydrology and water
flow are different.
They actually plant
at different times.
So a common rainfall shock,
even if it is actually common,
and shows up and all the
rain gauges which we have,
it's still the case that
it has differential impact
on the households, especially
depending on when they plant,
which is in turn a
function of soil and so on.
So what are Kamilya and I doing?
We're going to estimate
a three-stage production
function which takes into
account the sequential nature.
There's planting, for sure.
And then you have sort of
the germination period,
and the planting of
the rice, and so on,
with maybe some
fertilizing and so on.
Then you've got
sort of midseason,
and all the stuff
you need to do.
And then you finally
approach and include harvest.
You know, I'm going to jump,
and just show you the notation.
So here basically is stage
I, with predecessor stages I
minus 1.
It's going to be looking
forward to future stages
if you're not at the last one.
So if you're at the last one,
this would be the harvest.
That's the easiest
thing to think about.
If you're in the
next-to-last one,
the output is
basically the condition
of the crop prior to harvest.
And what influences that?
Well, if you've got
land, labor, capital,
and so on, as Cobb-Douglas
type inputs in the production
function--
but you've also got the
state of the crop plot
that you inherited from
the previous stage.
And then all of this gets
hit, at the end of the period,
with more shocks,
including rain, and so on,
and temperature.
So this is not a Cobb-Douglas.
It's a CES that allows
some substitutability
to be estimated between
the current state
and contemporaneous inputs.
It may not be as
extreme as Leontief.
So you're kind of doomed by
the state of the crop plot
at this time,
based on everything
that happened in the past.
And then you just have to
adjust inputs in proportion.
Doesn't have to be that
bad, but it turns out
not to be like Cobb-Douglas.
If you want to think
about Cobb-Douglas,
there's a whole lot
of substitutability--
labor today, labor tomorrow.
Oh, it's not that
much of a difference.
Why don't we wait and figure
out what the rainfall is first,
and then adjust
the inputs later?
So this allows us to estimate
the ability to adjust.
And essentially the
reason you can't
use rain, aggregated up
over the whole season,
is because of this
imperfect substitutability
across the stages.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: It says
that it introduces--
[INAUDIBLE] that
[INAUDIBLE] induces
people to plant at different
times, for example.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: No,
that's not in there.
There's a separate equation
that has to do-- like a probit,
basically, which determines
planting times as we see it
in the data.
So we can look at the effect
of rainfall on rice production.
And we can actually do
something with climate change.
Let me show you this thing.
So this black thing
here is the distribution
of actual yields
across households--
and actually it's
households and time.
This peak thing is just
using a weather index.
So you regress yields--
same data, our data, onto
temperature and rainfall,
and a whole suite of
them, a big, long vector.
It doesn't have to be,
narrowly, rainfall.
Try to be as
realistic as possible.
And then you run a regression.
And then you get basically
the predicted through the lens
of that weather index model.
And it's close.
It's very, very peaked.
Well, sorry, that's
the first thing.
Then this thing is
using the full model--
sorry, using the model, but only
the observed rainfall variable,
and setting everything else at
their sample average-- common
soil, common fertilizer.
And then the big jump
down here toward the data
is when you start to allow the
variation that the model has
in it, certainly soil variation,
and eventually full variation.
So we're not one to one with
the actual distribution,
but we've made a
substantial improvement
from simple weather indices.
So people talk about basis risk.
And what they mean
typically is the reason
there's not take-up of
a rainfall insurance
product is because the rain
gauge is way out there,
so distant that the correlation
of the rainfall at the gauge
with the correlation of the
rainfall in the village is low.
In fact, the Bank for
Agriculture introduced--
I guess it's now
three years ago--
an index product.
And they already restricted
it to be something
like 20, 25 kilometers.
And the take-up was terrible.
So then they said, oh,
we know, it's basis risk.
So then they went down
to something like 15,
lowered the radius.
And take-up was
still pretty bad.
And I think they're going to
have to withdraw the product.
So this is a kind of basis risk.
What we're saying
is, even though we're
sitting on top of
the rainfall gauge,
within the village, the
way that that rainfall
is impacting these farmers is
different across the farmers.
So we're busy sort of thinking
about designing, still,
a rainfall product, but
trying to take into account
this heterogeneity.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Maybe this is kind
of what you're getting at,
[INAUDIBLE] how flexible is the
sort of payout structure given?
I'm just trying to-- because
it seems like there's
kind of like, a [INAUDIBLE]
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah, so
let me show you Kapphan's--
her dissertation.
So here's her idea,
which is basically--
and this is typical
of the literature.
She did better than most.
You have a utility
function over consumption.
Consumption would
be autarky income.
But you have a payout--
could be positive or negative.
And that's a function of
this weather index, z.
So this is supposed
to be smoothing.
And this is an optimal
design problem.
It's output conditioned
on the weather index,
and then the distribution
of the weather index.
By the way, where is
she getting all of this?
She's doing it in the lab.
She's basically simulated
millet production
in Switzerland or something.
But she's not out looking
at the actual crops.
AUDIENCE: Is that
[INAUDIBLE] soil?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Hmm?
AUDIENCE: Is it
[INAUDIBLE] soil?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: I
don't remember exactly.
But that is a big
problem in practice
when you take these sort
of lab-type experiments.
I forgot to say, we actually
use a crop grow model as well.
It's called DSSAT.
And we carefully feed in soil
depth and soil into that model
I just showed you.
But to address
your question, sort
of optimized over this thing,
this is the policy design.
This is the optimal
contract design problem.
How cool.
I mean, it really is cool.
And you know, you can see,
in her simulated data,
the distribution of
yields for any index.
And then here's the
optimized payout,
which is basically positive,
definitely non-linear.
And basically it's
like [WHOOSHING NOISE]..
And many of the products that
people already came up with
are like these kind of
linear, flat schedules.
This has more wiggles, and
it's more non-linear than that.
But this is all
negative territory.
This is basically
ex-post premia down here.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So these
[INAUDIBLE] models,
do they try to account for
price changes that also result
from aggregate weather shocks?
[INAUDIBLE]
ROBERT TOWNSEND: No.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
everybody [INAUDIBLE]..
Because that could push it
in the opposite direction.
AUDIENCE: Yes, absolutely.
And I couldn't agree more.
Now, at some level, you've
got to either use data
to decide how price is moving--
that's a good starting point--
and/or incorporate in your
model like we saw with the macro
development models,
the movements
of wages and interest rates
and so on with interventions.
So you don't have to
do just one thing,
but you're right-- you need
to take it into account.
In Thailand, rice is
the dominant crop.
It's pretty hard to argue
that like the price of rice
in the village is a
function of village or even
necessarily regional rainfall.
AUDIENCE: It would have to
be a pretty big aggregate
[INAUDIBLE] price.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
So we want to do something
like that, that optimal design,
to take into account
what we've learned
about within-village insurance,
and their heterogeneity,
and so on.
Just two comments--
first of all,
is it true that
within-village stuff is great
and across-village stuff is not?
Well, in Thailand it's
not obvious at all.
And in Hong's helped with this.
We updated some earlier results.
But basically this
section of the slides,
which I won't
attempt to go over,
is how to test not only within
villages but across villages.
And then you can aggregate
it up, villages, and test
one county versus another.
So you have you have layered
sort of degrees of aggregation.
And you can use [INAUDIBLE]
method-- she did it in Kenya--
to see how good the insurance
is across the villages.
And in Thailand it's hard to
say that it's worse than what's
going on within the village.
So it's just
massive remittances.
There's just huge
financial flows coming in,
which we pick up in
the transactions data.
So I still have misgivings
about pushing too hard on this.
I'm sort of torn.
I'm torn by the attractiveness
of designing the intervention
based on the data, and yet
worried that they really don't
need this rainfall product.
And the other thing I want
to just point to so you can--
sorry, Hong, all your
great stuff here--
is to say that Chris Udry,
with Dean and co-authors,
have been doing stuff
in Ghana, and they
have various treatments.
They have rainfall insurance.
They have credit.
They have both.
They have one and the other.
They have controls.
And then you see stuff.
Like you see
sometimes that credit
seems to increase investment.
But you also see that the
combination of insurance
and credit is actually not
helping, although insurance
alone actually can help.
So they wrote down a model,
a simple two-period model,
which is clear about the
optimization problem.
And it's similar
in spirit to what
we're talking about
today, which is what's
the shadow price of current
consumption, what's the shadow
price of future consumption.
If there is full insurance--
which they assume
in the village--
and there are no
aggregate shocks--
which they assume in the model--
then basically you can get
counterintuitive effects going
on when you offer insurance.
Because insurance
moves tomorrow, it
makes tomorrow kind of less
valuable in some sense.
It actually seems to
undercut investment today.
And these other papers are again
treatments, RCTs and so on.
It's easy to get lost in
the details of these things,
and get caught up with
the language of take-up,
and behavioral responses, and
some very real things that
are out there.
But it's important
not to get lost,
and to remember the
basic sort of framework
that you're taking
in if you choose
to design one of these
randomized control trials.
Or let me put it another way.
If Udry had not been thinking
about those kinds of models,
he would be left with some
very strange puzzles that
does beg for an interpretation.
But even better
yet, when you have
the model and the structure,
ideally, with enough data,
you can actually
design interventions
which are informative about
key parameters in the model
and your guesses
about basic obstacles.